welcome everyone to the final lecture
let me just share my screen and we can
get going on this um
share screen
okay so this
lecture is going to be broken up to
three parts um first i'm going to do a
quick recap of the class
um then i'm going to talk about uh
future classes that you might
take hopefully this class has piqued
your interest in ai
and then finally i'm going to end with
some broad remarks on where ai is going
and what we should all keep in mind
so since it's a live lecture um feel
free to interrupt and ask questions i'll
monitor the uh chat
or if uh samara if you notice anything
you can flag it to me as well
all right so let's begin with a recap so
um no congratulations to making it so so
far in the in the quarter we've covered
a lot of ground
um so i'm just going to highlight some
of the key things that you should keep
in mind so recall
we started with this modeling inference
learning paradigm so modeling is the
what it's about how you build a
mathematical model that approximates the
real world it might be a neural network
might be a bayesian network
inference is the process of how you use
the mathematical model to answer
questions
it's trivial for neural networks but can
be really hard for bayesian networks and
learning is how do you take data and
produce a model so that you can do
inference on it
so
in this course we talked about machine
learning then reflex based models
state-based models variable-based models
and logic so let me just go through
each of them in turn
so in machine learning we presented the
loss minimization framework where you
have a training set and you want to find
parameters that minimize some loss and
one thing i want to stress is how
general of a principle this is the loss
captures basically kind of what you want
a classifier to have and we explored a
few different types of losses depending
on the task
and then we had a fairly simple
algorithm stochastic gradient descent
that was able to approximately optimize
these objective
functions
and this is really kind of the workhorse
of machine learning these two slides
it's
most of machine learning is can be you
know captured at least these days by
writing down a loss function and
optimizing it and it works for neural
networks it works for
um you know clustering and you know
problems and kind of k-means and and so
on
so i want to underscore that machine
learning is kind of a general
way of being it's the idea of taking
data and turning into models but there's
multiple types of models so we looked at
reflex reflex based models in the very
beginning
linear models neural networks nearest
neighbors inferences just feed forward
pass through the neural network
and learning we use to catch a green
descent or k-means in the case of
clustering
then we looked at problems where
you weren't interested in just a single
decision but you were interested in a
sequence of decisions from let's say
from getting to point a from to point b
and we embarked on the journey of
state-based models and here the idea of
a state is a summary of all the past
actions sufficient to choose future
actions optimally
and that crystally encapsulates what
kind of a state based model is and you
have lots of practice
coming up with state-based models for
various problems if they're
deterministic those are called search
problems you can use uh uniform cost
search or a-star if you have randomness
you modify smarthof decision processes
you can use things like value iteration
for inference and for games
these capture the cases where there's an
adversary and you have to use a min max
formulation
we for search problems we didn't really
touch on learning although you can do
that um
and and for
mdps and games
we have these reinforcement learning
you know algorithms so really you can
think about reinforcement as machine
learning for state-based models where
there's randomness in the environment
then we move on to variable based models
which is a higher level of abstraction
um it's a kind of a different modeling
language if you will
we looked at the key idea here is a
factor graph
which captures a set of variables whose
values you want to determine
and the the factors these are little
squares captures dependencies between
variables and the key thing is that the
factors are generally local but the
questions you want to answer are
probably global
so they're deterministic we have
constraint satisfaction problems for
things like scheduling
we looked at backtracking and beam
search
if you put on your probability hat then
we can turn these factor graphs into
markov networks by defining a
distribution
over all the random variables
for inference we looked at gibbs
sampling but there's other methods as
well and then
to give
a kind of a more of a
interpretation to how the factors are
constructed we look at bayesian networks
where each of the factors was a local
conditional probability and then we look
at uh four backward and particle forking
methods for um at least chain structure
bayesian networks there's much more to
be said about here this is just kind of
a taste
of variable-based models
um for loading we only look at learning
for bayesian networks
based on the maximum likelihood
principle but you can apply maximum
likelihood to any probabilistic model
including markov networks for bayesian
networks it was really nice because um
you know learning is closed form you
just count and normalize
for latent variables models you have the
expectation maximization algorithm
where you have to use inference to
impute the missing variables and then
you count and normalize
and finally we look at logic based
models
and here the idea of logic
is that
it goes a kind of one level of
abstraction higher it introduces things
called formulas which allows you to
represent more kind of powerful things
even kind of infinite things you can
talk about like all the even numbers for
example which is you know infinite set
um we look at
two models propositional logic and first
order logic um to do inference it
generally is pretty um hard
for propositional logic you can do
you know model checking or you can work
on the inference rules directly which is
one of the nice things about having
logical rules
modus ponens and resolution are
different
inference methods
so
you know sometimes i like to say and
logic is about how you can express kind
of very complicated things very
succinctly
and learning we didn't get to get a
chance to talk about but there are ways
to also bring machine learning to logic
so um hopefully
this
you know you see cs291 and and if you
haven't seen a lot of this material for
the first time it can be a little bit
overwhelming there's just so many models
tools
um methods
um but i hope that this kind of
organization gives you a way to think
about you know how everything fits
together right i don't want you to think
about like oh okay there's nearest
neighbors and there's bayesian networks
how are they related i i want you guys
to think about you know the trajectory
of
there's a bunch of models with different
kind of uh which are bucketed into
reflex state and variable and logic and
then you can do learning on on top of
that and that allows you to
um have just a much more
nuanced and
you know holistic picture of all the
methods in ai
um and what's important i think is that
you know the individual methods like
whether you use particle filtering will
change over time and in general in
applications you might have to use
something a bit more sophisticated so
hopefully this class has imparted on you
just kind of a way of thinking about you
know the modeling and the inference and
learning as separate so that
whenever you encounter a new algorithm
that you read a paper somewhere um you
can actually kind of incorporate it into
your conceptual map
okay that's all i want to say about the
recap are there any questions
can you uh throw some light on what
should be the first tool that we should
be using uh if we are presented with a
problem
what is a tool that you should try first
it really depends on the problem
i think these days it's very
natural and easy um to throw machine
learning supervised classification at
the problem
um and that makes sense when your
um you know problem involves you know
basically a single action it's high
dimensional you don't really know what
to do with it
um but for many problems like if you're
kind of scheduling or doing route
planning
or something a bit more structured um
you wouldn't want to necessarily start
with machine learning because in sort of
start with machine learning
you need to gather data and if you don't
have data then that might not be the
best place you know to start
so i don't think that there's any
one place to start um
and hopefully these
you can think about the cs291 toolboxes
i kind of the the first layer in the
breadth first search these are the
different options you should think about
is machine learning good or should this
should this be a search problem or
should this be a
bayesian network for example
most of the current machine learning are
reflex based um they're a low-level
intelligent comparative logic
interesting
point
um
we are in a very interesting time where
a lot of what we see is machine learning
and it's also very impressive how
a lot of the so-called reflex based
models are actually capable of doing
some fairly sophisticated things
like if you think about you know alphago
yes there was multi-college research
that allowed you to actually build a
competitive agent but even just like uh
um you know classifying a game board um
that i mean that could definitely beat
me at a goal um
so
you know it's
i think that
you know in
in cognitive science people talk about
system one and system two right and both
co kind of coexist system one is kind of
the reflexive um
agent uh making kind of
you know guesses at what uh what should
be the right thing to do and system two
is kind of the more rational well
thought out and reason path and i think
we need both and the two
need to kind of coexist and kind of feed
off of each other
um could you give some examples of ml
methods for search problems and logic
problems
uh so
search um a lot of things can be passed
as search problems so there's a whole
field called structure prediction which
your our goal is to output
a structure let's say a graph or a
sentence or
or something
and
um in those cases you often want to
learn how to do that
so there you actually combine
some search techniques so the inference
um
algorithm becomes you know search um
rather than just a fee for through a
neural network but the kind of the
learning part is is still the same and
we didn't talk about the structure
perception i think but it's a night um
you should look at it i think it's in
the slide still where
you are
um
able to
you know make a prediction using an
inference algorithm you get a prediction
you compare that with the the correct
prediction and you do a gradient update
um and learn logic
um
you know there's similar things you can
you could do for example markov logic is
a way of using combining kind of markov
logic in the context of markov networks
and markup networks you can estimate
using maximum likelihood
all right uh let's
yeah great questions um feel free to
put more in the chat but i'm going to
move on for now since there's a few
other things
um to get through
okay
so now you've taken cs221 maybe this was
your first class maybe you've taken um
by a bunch of other classes i want to
talk about
what else is related to cs2201 so first
of all i'm not going to give you a whole
list of the complete list of courses you
can see the list of ai courses on this
website
um but that isn't even the whole list of
courses which i think are relevant
so what i've done here is try to help us
understand what are the types of courses
that you might be interested in why you
might be interested in them and then i'm
going to go through each category and
give a few examples of the most kind of
popular ones
so
the the most kind of obvious type of
course is well here we've taken 221
we've
learned about some methods let's learn
more about methods let's learn about you
know monte carlo markov chain monte
carlo in general for example and these
tend to be a more general purpose
um
but that's not the only type of course
that i think is relevant so applications
are extremely useful of course we are
interested in you know applications
because that's the kind of real impact
of ai is when they're applied to things
but also in the other direction
often when you take an applied class you
learn the method much better than if you
take a kind of an abstract because you
appreciate when it works when it doesn't
work all the nuances
and then finally
i would really stress and kind of invest
in building depth for both kind of
methods and applications
and usually these are courses not in ai
they might
for a method side maybe i'm
investigating kind of more mathematical
foundations or an applied area if you're
interested in computational biology take
a biology class
um i think these days it's too
i think easy to kind of go through
um kind of an ai curriculum and not
really have as much depth
because you can you can do a lot with
with kind of just downloading you know
packages and running data but i think if
you really wanted to especially if you
think about kind of research
having the depth kind of can distinguish
you from
um and make you
more able to come and come up with kind
of new insights and ideas
so let's start with methods um
so these are categorized into maybe the
different topic areas that we've covered
in the class so first is you know
machine learning everyone else probably
knows about cs220 alliance so it's kind
of the standard um
you know poster child machine learning
class
um compared to cs221 i think there's
this question comes up a lot it's more
kind of mathematical derivations rather
than as much you know programming um
there's more continuous variables cs201
tries to shield you from that and deal
with discrete variables just
for the interest of kind of scoping and
you learn some kind of fancier things
like kernel methods and pca so if you
really want to dig in more into machine
learning
you know that's the class for you
if you are looking for just a kind of
more of how do i apply machine learning
especially deep learning which has been
you know increasingly important
you know the ts230 will tell you how to
train these duke neural networks which
um is
has a lot of you know
bells and whistles and things that you
need to know about like dropout and
batch norm um to make these things work
so if you're really interested in the
general practice of how you get deep
learning to work
that's a class for you
so there's three other classes
that i want to mention of course there's
more so the first class is machine
learning under distribution of shifts
so we have mentioned a few times that
machine learning fails when the training
distribution isn't the same as the test
distribution for example
um there's adversarial examples and this
class is
aimed at
telling you you know
what's going on there and what you can
do about it
um
often you think about machine learning
as uh kind of one task at a time but
increasingly now
we're seeing much more general learning
tools that allow you to generalize
across multiple tasks um so that's you
know pretty exciting
and finally we think about machine
learning often on kind of single data
points
which are less structured but you know
machine learning can be done in the
context of graphs
so there's a class
about that as well
then there's reinforcement learning if
you like the reinforcement learning
section
and want to know
more advanced methods take cs234
we get you get to learn about policy
search
um whereas we've looked at kind of more
like q learning which is that's maybe a
value function
um
then there's a decision making on
there's uncertainty from the erastral
you know department which focuses more
on model based if you remember
distinction between model based and
model free so in kind of more serious
uh you know applications you really want
to
have maybe a model of what's going on
in the world and you could do things
like planning rather than just like
being kind of a reflex agent
um general models if you enjoyed
bayesian networks um and markup networks
and this is the class for you cs228 um
probably graphical models it's kind of a
fairly kind of natural extension of the
things that we've talked about fancier
inference algorithms um how you learn
the structure and so on
um
recent in the last i guess i don't know
five years there's been a surge of
interest in um
you know general models which are
supercharged with deep learning and uh
if you have probably many people have
seen gans generating really photo
realistic images um this is all enabled
by deep generative models which builds
on the principles of general models but
you kind of combine it with deep
learning and you get you know
really
interesting results
so let's talk a little bit about
applications i'm only going to talk
about three applications vision language
and robotics of course there's
computational biology there's healthcare
and there's other things which um i'm
not gonna have time to mention
so vision there are uh
there's a kind of a
stock
i mean the the canonical vision uh class
is i guess at this point as cs231n
it's fairly machine learning heavy you
talk about like learn what confidence
and transformer so it's
more um general purpose than vision
but you talk about some you know vision
specific tasks like detection
segmentation generation
um
there is
cs231a which talks is more kind of on
the vision side so if you feel like
you've already
uh know your ml
but you really want to learn more about
kind of vision this might be a good um
class for you um because vision
ultimately is about how light you know
works in with um in the kind of a 3d
world
um and so you kind of get into that
there's also a i think a newish class on
how um
ai intersects with graphics which is
kind of a close cousin of vision
um and this is has some emphasis on kind
of generating things like generating
animation but also a much more
you know in-depth emphasis on kind of
rendering and geometry
okay so robotics uh
there's introduction to robotics where
you learn about um how to how you
explore kind of physical models of your
products how to kind of move arms and
how to relate kind of joint angles to
actually what the robot does in the in
the real world
um
cs2237 has a little bit more
uh
learning involved because for more
complex robotics tasks you can't really
do everything from first principles so
there's some learning involved but you
know you still need to
look at kind of the
you know the structure of the robotics
problems
um language there's a few language
classes cs224n is a kind of the standard
language uh class
um it is also
ml heavy just like cs231n
um it talks about a sun a bunch of
different language tasks like parsing
and translation
cs224u is um called natural language
understanding people ask like what's the
difference between processing
understanding
um
historically there used to be a bigger
difference but now with deep learning i
think these two classes have
you know have much more overlap um you
can look at the topics they're kind of
slightly you know different maybe more
emphasis on like i know semantics
um
there's a class on applications of
virtual assistants
and um next
quarter i'm actually going to be
teaching understanding and developing
large language models um so you might
have heard me talk about foundation
models or gp3 or things like that
beyond just the kind of the
the technical aspects of how these
models work and how they're built are a
lot of kind of social ethical legal
considerations um
so
we're going to talk about some of those
things as well as giving you hands-on
experience giving you access to these
large language models so you can kind of
feel them and kind of even train some of
them yourself so it should be an
exciting interesting class
okay so the third category is
foundations um there's many types of
foundations um these are more
mathematical foundations um so convex
optimization it's a great class
to
really kind of understand you know
optimization
so most machine learning people these
days think you know run s2d and that's
that's good and for many things that's
that's fine um for a kind of more
sloppy optimization that's fine
there are cases where you do want to
optimize your
um your utility function and you need to
do something more serious
so optimization and also this class is
actually a
you know i took this class in a similar
class in in grad school and that's
really when i started you know kind of
understanding linear algebra so i think
it's
even if you're not interested in
optimization
it gives you familiarity with thinking
about kind of uh you know linear algebra
um statistical inference so there's a
whole host of statistics classes which
is important to kind of think about so
you know machinery and statistics have
clearly a lot of overlap but they kind
of have different emphasis statistics
focus on more on kind of scientific
discovery especially learning more
engineering um so some of the questions
you might ask are different like you
care about like hypothesis testing and
confidence intervals and the validity of
your
inferences because you don't always have
just like a held out test set that you
can or validation set that you can
measure performance against like you
have in engineering um so a lot of if
you're thinking about you know more like
kind of scientific applications i think
a bit of rigorous statistical thinking
would be healthy
and there's a class
if you ever wonder
why does it all work why is machine
learning deep learning
why is it so effective you can take
machine learning theory
and it talks quite
in-depth about the kind of uh fairly
technical probabilistic tools like
uniform convergence that helps you
explain
or partially explain the success of
machine learning
um
although you know if you're it won't
answer the question why things work
there's a lot left to be understood but
it hopefully will give you at least a
little bit of taste of like oh okay now
i understand like
it's not just a kind of a you know all
heuristic there's some kind of
statistical principles behind what we're
doing
um cognitive
science and neuroscience are
kind of
other areas that feed into ai
kind of science you can think about as a
software we're thinking about the human
mind so this class uh talks about using
probabilistic programs remember from you
know the bayesian networks
kind of modules to model human reasons
so this is really kind of interesting
um and then
you can look at neuroscience which is
has to do maybe more with a clinical
hardware i mean this is a theoretical
neuroscience class so it's not actually
going to be real
um you know
you know hardware so to speak but you
ask questions like you know what is the
um you know back propagation which is
the bread and butter of um you know deep
learning actually you the brain can't
implement that because it's not a local
kind of rule so people have been
interested in these questions like what
is kind of a really plausible
approximation that kind of explains
learning so pretty interesting open
question there
okay to summarize um so here's the type
of classes methods so this is kind of
going straight in some sense you learn
about more advanced techniques general
purpose
all good but i would really encourage
you to also think about
applications of ai especially things
that you really interest you and
you know that you're passionate about
and they again they really help you
understand and appreciate the methods
that you're you're learning
um and do invest you know some time in
investing in depth
um and there's a lot of classes outside
ai at stanford so
definitely explore and don't limit
yourself just to kind of ai classes
um so just some just
general tips
uh
you know beyond taking classes
there are a lot of resources online
talks you know tutorials blog posts um
you know it's information rich and you
know you can learn a lot from just
watching things online if that mode of
learning works for you
some people prefer downloading code and
tinkering a lot of stuff thankfully is
still open source and people release
their code and tutorials
and just talk to professors and other
students about you know what um
not just like what classes to take but
how they think about ai in the world
because a lot of
um
you know learning is not written down in
some sort of formulaic uh
um
you know textbook i think the field is
moving so fast that i think sometimes
it's just like in the in the heads of a
few people
all right so that's the end of the
second section um i'll take any
questions now
so uh
is it okay to take 230 without first
taking 229. i believe the answer is yes
um if anyone has taken these uh feel
free to chime in i think 2 29
um you
i mean especially if you've taken 221
that should be more enough to take 230.
221 really gets you kind of there you
derive uh
you know a lot of different learning
algorithms and you know think about like
you know mixtures of gaussians and so on
which aren't um needed if you're just
interested in you know applying deep
learning
any other questions
what would be the best way to talk to
professors and other students
that is a good question
um
i guess ed is probably not going to be
super
i mean it's probably going to go dead
after the course um i guess email is
isn't always an option i mean the best
time to talk to a
you know professor other students is
during the quarter when they're holding
office hours and everything
but maybe
you know after the course there's still
some professors still have office hours
um is it okay to take 2204n without
previous experience in deep learning
um 224 the short answer is
uh yes because i think the first
uh
again condition on you haven't taken 221
you have kind of the the basics 224 n
starts with some of the basics of deep
learning um so you can get by
i think if you can take deep learning i
think that's better
um
i mean there's always this thing where
if you take
the more products you kind of take then
the more
time you'll be able to spend kind of
actually
you know enjoying the kind of language
aspect rather than let's say the deep
learning aspect
um cs2324
would be offered online
later
um
it's going to be offered in person in
the winter
um
nope
in the future
it's definitely a possibility haven't
thought
that far in advance
depending on how much interest there is
i guess
um what are classes that would be
offered remote
uh
for that you have to check the
um so i don't know which ones are remote
versus
in person i think by default
everything's going to be
attempt to be in person
i think
all right
um so i think that's a low in the
questions so let me move on to the third
part
okay so now we get to kind of step back
and think about where ai as a field
is going
um
so
you know if you think about where we are
today in in ai
i think of alphago as kind of
a quintessential
of image that captures you know the the
progress and the optimism that we're
feeling today right kind of a very bold
effort
surprised a lot of people
um experts
go of go and ai um and kind of really
was a kind of a triumph of of sorts for
you know ai and machine learning and
deep learning
and you kind of see this
kind of
optimism kind of
in boldness kind of continued with
things like you know gpt 3 which came
out last year open ai released this a
large language model
um 175 billion parameters trained on you
know a bunch of text
and orders of magnitude larger than the
previous model
and um the cost is something like you
know four or five billion or sorry four
or five million dollars billion would be
a lot um and one thing that's
interesting is just a language model so
remember a language model is just
something that
takes a context and predicts the next
word
so you think about this is the world's
most boring task like why would you want
to just predict the next word but it
turns out that if you do this at scale
you can do
all sorts of other things like you can
get it to
convert natural language into sql
queries or you can have do question
answering
with a
in a dialogue format
you know it doesn't do any of these like
particularly well but the mere fact that
now you have a single model that can if
that wasn't trained for these tasks
doing anything sensible is impressive
it's like
the question isn't how well the bear
dances is like
bears dancing at all in in some ways and
this has led to a whole era of um large
models which are you know really
improving the accuracy across the board
on
mostly kind of language tasks for now
but you see it in vision as well
so
and it's kind of this optimism that's
in progress that's really leading to ai
being kind of deployed
you know across a countless number of
different areas from you know
all the consumer services like you know
think about facebook or google but also
in other types of you know areas as well
although obviously to a lesser extent
because they don't have as much kind of
you know ai expertise as the tech giants
and it's also being applied
in even
you know many areas like education or
credit employment
which really starts to kind of affect
you know people
right you know that said like some of
these ai systems are like logistical
russia not gpt3
many of them are actually closer to
logistic regression than gpg3 but
nonetheless this whole umbrella of uh
you know using data methods to automate
certain types of decision making is a
general trend that encompasses many
different regimes
so now what i want to spend the last
kind of lecture
reflecting on is what is the societal
you know impact of this of this trend
um
having spent a whole quarter time
talking about the you know the
technology um so i just want to use a
simple example you know machine
translation you know many of you
probably used it
um
and it's one application where
just the quality of machine translation
has just improved significantly due to
advances in ai
and which is great it can help break
down language barriers increase
accessibility improve the kind of
productivity of the economy and and so
on
um
and so this is you know generally
positive
um but there's always a kind of
you know you look at the kind of the
flip side of things um
and
while they're ubiquitous they have
problems
so for example hungarian is a language
that doesn't distinguish between
female male
third-person pronouns
so when you translate into english it
has to guess what the the gender of a
pronoun
is and you can see that it patterns very
stereotypically a long kind of
professional stereotypes
um and these kind of biases are
you know sometimes if you i mean you
don't bother to think about it maybe
don't uh
you know seem to raise a alarm but i
think these are actually kind of the
the you know the frog and better alive
kind of uh setting where it starts kind
of creeping insidiously throughout you
know society and gets amplified
um so it's something really to be
you know careful of
there's also weirder stuff so there's
kind of one example um from a few years
ago where in some you know maori which
is a i guess a language that doesn't
have that much data you type in some
nonsense dog dog dog and you get some
uh really disturbing stuff coming out
um and no one really knows why this is
kind of happening
i think many of these issues are due the
fact that machine learning thrives on
these complex models fitting
spurious or fitting correlations in data
so it's like we're kind of pushing the
limits of what we can do and that that's
kind of the
the
the kind of outlook i think the field
has had
for quite some time i mean you have to
remember that even you know 10 years ago
like computer vision basically didn't
work
uh and so people are like really for
decades trying to get things to work at
all and now things work
well now we have other things to worry
about
so i want to highlight something called
spurious correlations which i think is
you know a
cautionary tale
so here's a task um you know it's a
pretty solid test you take an x-ray
image of a chest and you're trying to
predict whether there's a collapsed lung
or not
and
if you take a standard
you know computer vision machinery this
works pretty well
uh but you know take a closer look at
this uh this image see that tube coming
out here
that's called a chest strain
and it's something that's it's a common
treatment for collapsed lungs
okay so
and it turns out that this is one of the
signals that the model is picking up on
so it looks like hey this person was
treated for clubs long therefore
um you know he has a collapsed lung
okay so if you look at
um the the accuracies
the eoc of
um
here is the set of the entire population
here the people who have gotten chest
strains
um they're damn you're predicting on
them much more likely accurately than
the people without chest strains
so you might seem like oh okay we're
doing pretty well but actually
you know first a segment of a population
that doesn't have chest strains you're
doing actually pretty you know not not
so well
and this is exactly the subpopulation of
untreated patients that you actually
care about because if they already have
a chest strain like you don't need a
prediction whether they have a klopse
lung or not
so
this kind of is a cautionary tale that
you really need to
not just look at the accuracy but kind
of really understand
how the model is actually making that
prediction because if it's just latching
onto spurious correlations and you go
deploy this
it might not be so good
here's another example
suppose you're trying to figure out the
effect of a treatment on survival of
patients so here
maybe you did some study
and here's the data so for untreated
patients eighty percent survive and for
treated patients thirty percent survive
so the question is does the treatment
help
so
how many people think it helps
so maybe raise your hand if you think it
uh
you know doesn't help
or just put something into the chat
that's fine too
i'm trying to make this a little bit
interactive
get people to think
doesn't help
that's possible unclear whether helps
yeah who knows it's right
um
you know if you're you're very naive
about it you can think like oh okay well
it's correlated survival is correlated
with
not treating
but
um exactly um
you know sick people are more likely to
undergo treatment
so there's a hidden confounder here
which is you know how sick you are so
this doesn't tell you anything
so if you're just doing machine learning
naively
you could really be doing completely the
wrong thing
and there's this whole field of causal
inference which provides kind of
rigorous machinery to help you
answer these kind of questions
and especially kind of in these kind of
high stakes medical settings where
there's maybe not lack of data in lack
of ground truth you really really need
to be careful right like for machine
translation you kind of can get a human
to look at the sentence like yep seems
reasonable and this is kind of the more
typical engineering attitude like i try
it and i can always validate you if it
works like when you can validate when it
works yeah maybe maybe it's okay to use
something that
you maybe don't fully understand but
like when you have to
rely on
when there's no validation i think you
have to lean more much more on kind of
first principles
okay so
cautionary tale is um always be aware of
the limitations of a technology and
machine learning definitely has a lot of
you know limitations and i think it's
really important that you walk away with
this class not thinking like oh yes
machine learning let's now i know how to
do sgd i get a data set and i can just
go with it you have to be
aware of the limitations
all right so now um the second part of
this um you know the module i'm going to
talk about ai aifx so
many of you probably have heard
the term aifix kind of thrown around
it's often in use it's um you know often
kind of there's a lot of
you know heat kind of around this term
like you know
ethics people are not being ethical and
what's going on here
and um you know what the the broadest
level it's it's about how we ensure that
ai is developed to you know benefit
society and not harm society okay so
sounds
sounds easy not easy but like you know
uncontroversial right um
and and there's a lot of
principles and people have written a lot
about this so i'm not an ethicist so i i
mean i don't can't speak to this kind of
in in great depth but you know starting
with the kind of the belmont report from
the 1979 on human subject research and
there's an acm code of ethics and all
these companies are now putting on
alkyne responsible ai principles and so
on it seems like there's a lot of
guidelines
um which is which is good um
often these things say like you know
respect persons don't do harm to people
um and which you look at and you say
okay well
yeah um yeah i don't want to harm people
but the real question is like how does
how do these high level principles
relate to
the concrete actions you take because a
lot of these ethical issues aren't about
like any
malice or
um in mis misguided kind of intent it's
really about kind of
um you know
has to do with kind of ignorance if
you're not aware of something then um
bad things can happen even if you're not
aware of something
okay so what i'm going to do is walk
through a few specific considerations
which has to do with this umbrella
you know ai ethics which hopefully
gives you a bit more concrete guidance
so there's the considerations are data
um there's one objectives you optimize
there's inequality which we've talked
about before
our idea of harmful applications um
which
um i'm gonna get uh um some you know a
survey of people so get ready for that
and then automation versus augmentation
all right so
moving on
so data
so
ai is largely powered by machine
learning and without data there's no
machine line
so we must naturally ask the question
like what is this data that we're
talking about
so
here's an example
um
there's a data set called tiny images 80
million images which has been used since
uh 2006 in the computer vision community
and it was actually taken down
um because uh it was found to have
various kind of offensive content you
know in it even image then had some of
these kind of uh
um objectionable you know issues and it
was kind of cleaned up you know
afterwards
so
you know a lot of the times you know ai
systems are relying on web script data
and we know sometimes on the web it's
not a prepaid place and if you're just
scraping data and not very carefully
looking at it you can kind of inherit a
lot of these kind of offensive
material
uh
second of all um
you know there are historical biases
inherent in data so kind of social
biases with race and gender um even if
they're not offensive the idea that you
know maybe the lack of representation of
certain kind of marginalized populations
is itself kind of a problem so you have
kind of two types of problems one is you
can represent people or uh badly or you
cannot represent them and both are you
know things to worry about
so there's an another um
maybe
thing that
people don't normally think about when
it comes to data
which is that um you know should a piece
of data let's say if
i go on a vacation and take a picture of
my dog
and i post it on flickr
and then some big tech company scrapes
it and then does some pre-training and
uses it to do some scene classification
is this is this good
or i mean is it should it be allowed
right and right now i think the there's
no
we're kind of pretty lazy fair about
this where internet scrapes are kind of
the norm
um
and there's no there's no consent here
there's maybe i mean a lot of things are
copyright and um i'm sure there's tons
of copyright you know potentially
copyright violations
so this kind of
there's a question like data is produced
by people for
doing certain activities right i send i
post an article i write a book i send
messages to people
and
you know machine learning is something
that kind of sits on top and kind of
siphons that data for
usually another purpose
and the question is
you know whether
what right do i have to say like no that
should be allowed or not allowed and
often this kind of goes without even
your users being aware of what's
happening
so another piece of data that is
important is um
you know how much work it takes to
produce it
so often we think about you know
technology
and machine learning methods because
that's kind of well i mean from a
computer science perspective that's kind
of the object of study
uh but more and more i think it's
important to be aware that
um
you know data takes you know what's
powering all these things
right like you think of ai as reducing
human labor it makes things more
efficient and so on but it's not free
and it requires resources so this is
excellent book by mary gray and
siddharth suri called ghostwork that
kind of documents the amount of kind of
human labor usually crowdsourcing that's
used to create data sets
um or moderate flag content um that is
used to power these ai systems so a lot
of ai systems are
have the kind of a veneer being like
automated
but really they're kind of
you know being powered by people at some
level
um
there's a kind of one example i want to
point out
which is good food for thought is
you know in machine learning we like to
think about the distinction between
label data
which is really expensive to obtain
because you have to like pay people to
label it and unlabel data which is cheap
or even free right
um
but if you think about it if you go back
to what i said about data is created by
people
expanding capital right think about like
quote-unquote raw text books and
articles
um
it's free because well we just
took someone else's book that they spend
a lot of a whole year writing and we
didn't pay them for it right that's why
it's free
and so so it's kind of
important to kind of keep that
perspective that you know a lot of
machine learning is um kind of deriving
value from
um
uh you know the labor of people
um who are not getting compensated um
you know for the asset
so you know just a little bit of
perspective
all right so
the second uh topic is objectives um
so optimization is largely touted in
this class it's a powerful paradigm it
allows you to express a desire in the
form of an objective function
and then
separate that from like you know the
intense resources and algorithms to make
it kind of come true you make a wish and
then
you know you can get it to come true
that's the kind of a power optimization
but the question is what should the
objective be
right
ideally it would be something like you
know happiness or you know productivity
but usually these things are impossible
to measure
so often we have surrogates
for them
and um so okay now we're not getting the
thing we actually care about because
their circuits are approximations
and further more there's kind of
different incentives right you know
businesses are
always incentivized to maximize you know
profit you know
i mean nothing against them that's what
they're designed to do and um that's not
always aligned with kind of what's the
benefit for the you know the social good
um
and
you know so just an example um you know
most internet companies use clicks or
views as a major component of their
objective function
why because it's it's the signal that
they have and it's really good at
driving up kind of profit and usually
it's actually you know it does
reasonable things it gives you what you
say you want
but you know obviously what people's
reflexive actions are at any given time
are not necessarily represented their
long-term goals
and moreover at societal level we see
that this leads to potentially big
problems like polarization which is you
know a whole other topic that it won't
get into
so so i think it's always important to
think about like what the
objectives that you've kind of set out
to be and beware of any sort of
surrogates or misalignment incentives
inequality we've talked about kind of a
machine learning lecture where um
remember the gender trades a project
where um
different gender uh
kind of image recognizers work
differently on different uh populations
of people
um
you know what do you do about this um
well you can
collect more data
uh for certain types of groups but often
this is hard to do and more expensive so
you know there might not be kind of uh
incentives to do this
unless there's you know regulation
one solution is data the second solution
is in the methods we looked at how you
can minimize the maximum group loss
using group pro
and uh you can you know mitigate some of
these performance disparities
you know of course
you know it's a big philosophical
question like what kind of tradeoffs you
you want to you know
take which you've had the
opportunity to kind of reflect on in in
the homework
but one thing i want to mention is you
know the idea of auditing auditing i
think is a really
powerful force because a lot of systems
especially commercial systems are you
don't really know what's going on
in them right and in the gender shades
example after the study came out
um you know companies were incentivized
to fix the problem and after you know a
period of time you know disparities were
largely vanished
so just like by the mere fact of
studying what systems are doing
can
actually sometimes be enough to
incentivize companies to take action
okay so now i'm going to do a little bit
of
audience participation so get ready to
kind of raise your hands
so
there's a question of
what applications are
are ethically okay
okay so this is gonna be um interesting
and moreover
you know when a researcher makes a kind
of advance how do you assess its
potential harms
okay so
um here's one
autonomous weapon systems powered by ai
that can track objects and
fire
missiles or whatever
so
maybe you can vote either
up if you think this is a okay
application or
a down if you think this is not okay
application
okay so i think most people who voted
say
no if not all okay so this is
should be an easy case i don't know what
everyone else thinks hopefully this
should be
um okay so maybe maybe there's some
um
you know i think
you could maybe make a case for uh
this but i think this is
largely
um in the community regarded as like
very very you know ethically problematic
at the very least
so uh i i wrote yes for a defensive role
because i was thinking like uh if
just like there was an uh attack uh and
the israeli
uh autonomous system were able to defend
missiles and that protected a lot of
people then in that perspective it might
be
uh good to have automatic
yeah so um i'm not going to get into the
kind of detail argument i think you can
debate these things for a long time but
um
but i think i'm trying to kind of bring
a together a spectrum um so
i think this is one example which most
people think is
is uh very problematic so what about
deep fix
so again vote how many of you think this
is okay technology
versus not okay
um so
you know they have genuine use cases um
maybe an entertainment like if you want
to create like an avatar or something or
pretend you're a you know a celebrity
um
[Music]
but on the other hand of course i mean
as this picture points out you can fake
you know barack obama or some head of
state into to
doctor your video that gets them to say
you know anything
so obviously this is a potentially
pretty problematic
um
from a point of view of uh this
information
where people can't tell what's
fact or what's fiction
so what about image generation
okay so this just gets a little bit more
interesting so suppose you you you know
you're not generating barack obama
you're just generating you know few
puppies okay how many of you think this
is okay now cute puppies yeah okay who
doesn't want more cute puppies
um
okay so more
yeses
but you know
intuitively feels like it should be okay
because you kind of distance yourself
from
you know any sort of weaponry
but
you know the truth is that
a lot of the
methods that you see
is actually general purpose
right like if you can generate cute
puppies you can generate
barack obama
right so this is where i think the
ethical
dilemma comes about which is this idea
of dual
purpose technology
right it can the same technology can be
used for
um
putting a smile on your face or
um
you know spreading disinformation
and
you know there's no
you know i'm not going to offer any
solution if even if there were
uh you know solution but this is
something that
needs to be kind of just the process of
thinking about this while you're doing
ai is extremely important
and you can even go farther and say what
about deep learning
okay so
maybe most people would say
yeah deep learning is probably fine
because there's so many good things you
can do with that
but i mean some people would argue that
the idea of the developing technology
that enables large organizations to you
know amass data and
you know have centralized power and all
that is you know inherently evil so you
could take that position as well
so there's no
you know right or wrong answer here but
i think there's just a spectrum of
viewpoints and
i think a lot of the ai
ethics is this process of debate and
reflection as opposed to
um it should not be like here are the
principles if you just follow them
um then you'll you get a
stamp of approval it's not like that at
all it's about like internalizing these
these questions
and carrying them with you at all times
okay so the final thing i want to talk
about is
automation versus augmentation
um
so ai
is
you know you see a lot of news like oh
ai
is um it's dangerous because it can
replace
jobs or you may think about like a hai
that goes rogue
um and i think a lot of this
whether it be a kind of a real worry or
not has to do with the framing itself
ever since the beginning and the
inception of ai
there's this kind of this idea of an
agent that is supposed to be
intelligence or wanted to be
intelligence
and it can do things in the world right
and once you call it an agent that means
it has agency that means it can do
things that are you know it's it's kind
of own entity in some sense
and if you frame it like that
then now you're just fighting uphill
battle to coax it to be aligned with
human values and it's like wait wait no
i didn't mean that let's get it to do
what we want
and this is so deeply unframed in in the
grain it deeply ingrained in the framing
of the eye from things like the turing
test which is about an agent that can
actually deceive a human being um for
what it's worth um rl agents that kind
of are autonomous and doing their things
and the whole idea of gen ii
artificial general intelligence and this
leads kind of to a very um
you know explicit kind of automation
in perspective
because well you have an agent it's
doing things um now
it's it's gonna you know do the thing
that the human was doing
now if you go back to the 1950s there
was another kind of
line
of thinking which is interesting called
ia
intelligence augmentation or
amplification
um which was about creating tools that
help humans and this is kind of in some
ways like kind of a predict predecessor
of
hci human computer interaction which
focuses on the augmentation of
human abilities
so now
this in some ways i think is
you know more amenable to
um i think this perspective allows us to
kind of sidestep a lot of these kind of
problems because baked in into the the
premise of
ia is like we are trying to
make humans you know smarter or faster
or whatever
and it's human-centric or as opposed to
kind of agent-centric
so a lot of these kind of you know
interesting you know moon ai moonshots
like the turing tests or asian that can
play chess
would not be have pursued under kind of
an ia you know agenda
and
you know for
it's clear today that ai has by focusing
on the asian perspective it has led to a
lot of powerful technology
but it's also clear that we need a lot
more kind of ia thinking to help shape
this technology
because fundamentally we should be
developing ai to improve you know the
human condition
okay so this is final slide um
so ai is a technology
and like most powerful technologies it's
a dual use technology which means that
it can
improve efficiency accessibility
productivity dare i say happiness i
don't know
um
you know it can do a lot of good things
but it can also do a lot of damage it
can
be explicitly used to harm you know
people but even you know putting that
aside
i think even
by virtue of not being cognizant of
certain issues it can exacerbate social
inequalities you can do harms without
you know people thinking about it which
is why i want to kind of
stress so much the idea of just being
aware of these issues i think is kind of
half the battle in terms of making
progress here
and you know the final takeaway is
you know just because you can build
something doesn't mean necessarily that
you should maybe you should maybe you
shouldn't
um you should always ask yourself you
know what are the benefits and what are
the risks
and this might mean sometimes slowing
down and challenging the status quo
which is uncomfortable because we're
used to thinking about charging ahead
and march you know in the march of
progress and there aren't any easy
answers um but i think really mindful
deliberation
can go a long way here in making ai more
ethical
all right so that is the end of
the lecture
um hopefully you guys learned a lot and
hopefully this was good food of for
thought um please give feedback on
course evaluation on access and thanks
for
an exciting quarter
all right i think we have
um a bit of time for questions
um
more to hear your thoughts about uh sort
of flight that you had regarding the
deep fake and then picture generation
things like that um so
i feel like
a while ago you want to verify something
find out about something you read it up
from a verifying source in the intellect
and then it was like um
if you have a video of a person talking
that's more reliable because content you
can't trust but now deep breaks videos
are not so reliable
a sense of an erosion of verifiable
truth
uh in digital content
um for this
what you might be what your thoughts
will be on that
yeah i mean everything you said is true
we can't really trust uh what we see
um online i mean this is
gonna be even more true kind of going
into the
in the future
um i don't think all hope is lost and
that just means we need to kind of reset
our expectations and have other
mechanisms for
you know validation
um
and
you know i think that
um i think maybe
there are non ai things you could
attempt to do for example you know
authentication of
um you know providence of like okay this
video or
this image or this text was actually
produced by this
um you know entity at this particular
time and were placed and it was
certified
um
and you have to design a kind of a you
know secure mechanism for
you know
authenticating so this is more in the
kind of realm of you know security
but you know
another example is um you know photoshop
exists
and i think we're all
okay
um you know i think we
maybe
i mean video might be a little bit more
kind of you know visceral in some sense
but you know routinely there's images
that can easily be photoshopped with
high-fidelity and
we don't necessarily trust those
so
um
i think
you know what i guess i'm
trying to
not avoid sounding too pessimistic about
you know the future that there are
things we can do
but we do need to do them
and i think that
you know when developing our technology
um you know it's going to happen if you
know eventually i think it's most of
this is kind of just
buying us type
right until
and kind of slowing things down enough
so that we have time to react i think
you know in
20 years i don't think there's any way
that's gonna no way you can stop people
from having
you know deep fakes
i mean it's much much earlier than 20
years but just to give a upper pound
thank you
[Music]
less and less harmful in the longer hand
just like
um
like more like if everyone in the world
can train their models
um
not necessarily i think um
i don't like using an analogy but like
if you imagine everyone can build a nuke
in their
you know
backyard doesn't mean that things are
better and
in the
it could just lead to an arms race
between attackers and defenders
as well
whoever has the most powerful model can
kind of win
i mean it's really interesting
because
you know i've been such a big proponent
of like transparency and openness and
you know we in research you just put
everything out right you're supposed to
that's your
that's kind of the
the whole
idea of you know science but sometimes
there are technologies and there's a
situation where
maybe it can do harm
sense
yeah
one question is what constitutes common
sense uh there has been a bunch of work
um
in common sense reasoning in the last
five years yejin troy as as a professor
at uh
university of washington has done a lot
of excellent work in this area
used to be like common sense reasoning
was talked about
you know before machine learning and
people didn't really work on it but now
it's kind of coming back um so
um but it's it's it's tricky it's really
a slippery concept what constitutes
common sense and how you
get your hand around it
thank you
any other questions
what are some good sources to
[Music]
you know what is latest happening in ai
industry
what is the latest that's sorry
happening in ai industry
yes so
in different fields
so what is the new technology coming up
for the application to build on
um you're asking just generally what
happened
so you're asking for references where
you can find out about how
to keep up with the latest ai or you're
asking people what i
um
yeah i don't know if there's a
definitive source i mean
you know
archive i guess provides a lot of the is
a feed of the latest papers often
um blog posts or twitter
um
you know people
uh post a lot of kind of recent advances
there
um
i guess social medias
for lack of better uh
you know
concrete description
i mean i would say that it is a very
biased you know sample it's the things
that are generally done in research
done in like kind of prominent you know
research labs
um
i think which which is good i mean i
think it's it's yeah follow other ml
researchers on twitter that's how you
learn about stuff
um i think there's also a lot of ai
that's
you know in the kind of private
organizations where people aren't
publishing and there it's can be hard to
figure out you know what's going on
anything else
why do people publish models even if
they are expensive
there are i think multiple reasons um
publishing models allows other people to
build on top of
work so it's good for the community to
have more
you know sharing you know you can make
progress faster
also you get recognition more on a kind
of selfish note if other people built
on top of your work
that's kind of the academic
you know model in some sense
okay well if there's nothing else then
let's end there
thanks everyone again for coming to the
last lecture
um after a whole quarter of modules i
guess it's it's kind of nice to get a
little bit of life interaction although
i guess i've seen many of you at the
faculty chats um so that's been nice
um but yeah good luck with the rest of
your quarter and
see you next time
you